[Music]
2006 communications forum series I'm
David warbird director of the
communications forum I'm happy to see
you all here I would be happier if there
were more of you but I remind our guests
that we are in touch with an
international audience through our
website and through and through the
audio recordings and now video video
that are archived on our site and we
should reach we should reach a
considerably larger audience than this
than the folks who are here and my hope
is that as is often the case with forums
some folks will be coming in as we speak
I'm going to be very brief in my
introductions because we have a full
venue and I'm hoping for a very exciting
conversation Robert Pinsky is the poet
who is the former poet laureate of the
United States the only one the only man
poet in American history to serve three
terms as poet laureate from 1997 to 2000
he's the poetry editor of the online
journal slate he teaches in the writing
program at Boston University and is the
author of a series of remarkable books
of poetry of which the most recent is
Jersey rain and then a forthcoming chat
book about to appear I think later this
month or next month called first things
to hand one of his most recent
publications which we will have a chance
to talk about a bit later in our
conversation is a very interesting in
some ways surprising book for Robert
Pinsky a book called the life of David
it's not about me however it's about the
biblical King David much to my dismay
when he told me that also sitting at our
at our at our at our conversation table
is my colleague from MIT Todd mock over
he's the head of the media labs hyper
instruments and opera of the future
group he's the creator of the toy
symphony and international music
performance and education project and is
kind of a legend at MIT for his
imaginative way of bringing a classical
attitudes toward music together with new
technologies and with experimental forms
of various kinds we're going to begin
today by showing a
fragment of an opera that Pinsky and
Micawber have collaborated on and then
they will talk about it I thought I
would just quickly just show you a
little bit about the opera and then
we'll show you a couple of minutes of it
called death and the powers and Robert
deny I called Robert out of the blue to
see if you might want to collaborate on
a project several years ago and thank
God he said yes it's been a very very
interesting project it's still in
process
Robert finished the libretto about four
or five months ago and so I've started
on the music it's a quite a wild project
they will tell you a little bit about
the story later it's about a man joins
trying to say two words about what the
story is he's a billionaire sort of a
Rupert Murdoch - Walt Disney character
he's a creative billionaire who was
getting a kinda like Robert you know
it's kind of do immortality by having
himself converted into software he's
leaving the meat machine and he's
basically abstracting himself and this
has implications for his family who may
or may not follow him into this state
and also because he's so rich for the
world in the world economy and there's
subtitle it's a robot pageant the whole
show is put on by robots and our robots
won't look like any robots you've ever
seen and in fact the biggest robot of
all is as the set itself because one of
the ideas is that this character Simon
powers decides that he wants to leave
everything about himself in the world
even though he himself wants to leave so
he turns himself in to his environment
and the stage itself is a big robot it's
made up of gigantic panels that move
into different configurations as you can
see the panels themselves look like a
room at first and then they start to
vibrate and undulate in fact the floor
does as well all the surfaces that you
wouldn't expect come alive and somehow
whether we're gonna make this stage say
haven't quite figured that out yet but
characters all kinds of unusual things
happen with the characters as well so
objects that usually stay on the ground
like grand pianos don't they float as
well so this is a scene with the third
wife Evie who floats and dances with
Simon in the walls and the piano plays
while it's in the air this is my
favorite shot so far of the animation of
the set because it also the whole thing
explodes and goes onto the audience
don't sit in the front row for that one
we'll see
and we're also collaborating with a few
other wonderful people on this project
Cynthia Brazil who works here in the
Media Lab is designing the robotics for
the set and for a variety of objects
Randy Winer who's a writer and dramaturg
worked very closely with Robert to help
craft the story the story's Roberts but
to get it just right for an opera Randy
was extremely helpful Diane Paulus is
the theatrical director wonderful young
new york-based director who is
exceptional because she's very
well-known for her classical opera
Mozart and Monteverdi in particular she
also has a variety of kind of cult hit
off Broadway shows in New York that have
been running for a long time the donkey
shows one of them if you've heard of it
and she also designs a lot of the
theatricals for Disney these days and
Alex McDowell is the designer he's the
one who's helping us figure out how to
make these walls feel like they're alive
he's one of the very best Hollywood film
designers right now he designs all of
Spielberg's movies including Minority
Report the terminal and also does Tim
Burton's movies so he did Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory and Corpse Bride
if you've heard of those so we are
starting to make this project now it
opens in two years in Monte Carlo I'm
starting to compose the music we're
designing the sets and building
everything and we put on a little sneak
preview which we're going to show you a
teeny bit of right now in Monte Carlo in
the fall if you look at the top left the
characters these are the four main
characters the person on the all the way
on the left is Evie the third wife in
the black dress she's sung by Elizabeth
coy
who was a boston-based mezzo soprano the
person next to her to her left holding
the wheelchair is Nicholas who's
a kind of grad student scientist
assistant to Simon powers and he's the
one who has to know how to actually
build this system and his role is son by
the tenor Brian Grohmann next to him is
Simon powers the main character with the
white shirt and his sleeves rolled up
he's sung by the baritone James Madalena
great singer who if any of you have seen
any of John Adams operas he originated
the role of Richard Nixon and Nixon and
China for instance and on the end
wearing the black shirt and the skirt is
Miranda the daughter was about 12 years
old and she's sung by remarkable young
singer an eighteen year old on new
yorker freshman at Manhattan School of
Music named elizabeth writer so now I'll
just let's give you a tiny glimpse of
what this is going to be like this is a
the simplest possible set no set at all
just the performers and I put together a
little three-minute excerpt so you can
hear it so to make that louder please
[Music]
[Applause]
I guess I should say I don't get out
well David Moore if Todd for the
compression is he edited out my favorite
part right at the beginning there the
first words that this guy sings are the
beginning of the ages 7 to Byzantium he
says one side of nature I will never
take my bodily form from any natural
thing he says the Dada Dada da Dada Dada
the immortal William Butler Yeats with
his bird and he says something like
mechanical parakeet yeah
mechanical parakeet he says gold enamel
a mechanical parakeet and then he says
Yeats you can have your bird Yeats and
you edited out the part within Jimmy
Maddalena says yes I give you the bird
and I don't know if that was your
delicacy Todd but for the I want an
audience
I'm just like David that would that's
right here we took out the obscenities
for now but I said it's not it's an
interesting and in some ways one would
think of it as partly a problematic
collaboration between someone who spends
his time worrying about the nuances of
vowel sounds and consonant sounds at the
end of words and then having it
translated into this environment in
which people sing it it's surrounded by
music for me there's a kind of freedom
in the composition
I knew that pod was going to set these
things to music I don't have a wide
knowledge of modern music I actually did
know Todd's music and as you can tell
it's quite melodic and emotional and it
really is very referential for me it's
referential to all kinds of familiar
music so that it's an exciting feeling
for me thank God will have super titles
my main problem with it is that as with
heavy metal music as with many kinds of
music it's hard to understand the words
and I have never liked the art song if I
know the poem as you say I'm thinking
about the original music that is built
into the vowels and UV the less I know
the poem the better I like the art song
and in this case I had the freedom of an
effect writing for this format and I
could I could throw in rhymes and false
rhymes and little iterations and feel it
was like playing it was like a it was
the freedom of rather new medium so as a
way of composing I had no confidence in
my ability to make a good story for the
stage and that's where Randy Reiner was
very useful
almost as my psychiatrist make this work
I had the what Todd has done with the
words is very beautiful to me very
expressive and it was not I was not
saying goodbye to poetry I can write a
poem whenever I like or whenever I can
it was adding this other kind of
composition which I found very
liberating very pleasurable talk a
little bit about the
sequence of the work Robert did all his
work first and then you work from that
text is that yeah but usually so I I've
always liked not just like but I think I
write best to text and I probably write
melody more naturally than other things
as well
and so I'm also very inspired by texts
so I for a piece like this I thought a
lot about it had many many ideas but
nothing was absolutely specific until I
saw not just saw some words but saw thee
words so but Robert and I spent a huge
amount of time together over those you
know few years actually talking about
the story and talking about specific
texts and then you know sometimes we
work together sometimes Robert work with
Randy but I didn't write a note of music
until again not until there were
sections but I usually like to imagine
the whole shape of of a thing and the
personality of a piece and of these
characters so I got the whole libretto
and then really dug in that's when I
started writing I do hope that people I
I think the sound system in here is
awful I might be my goal I think the
text lights ain't that great either but
yes there's a lot of vestnik humour
political allusions Todd is leaving out
a false start in which we wrote an aria
is like one false step we went to Monaco
we had a soprano who sang the area at
the for the people in Monaco and with
that false start and with this project
so far Todd will email me and say
something like there are a lot of
syllables right here can you find a way
to use fewer syllables and I pride
myself on because the music requires of
course the exigencies have needed to
compose music for it is that a fair
paraphrase I'm sort of forgetting things
like that yeah there's a simpler word
here instead of a longer word simpler
word long word I know you just never you
know you never know what's gonna come up
in sport of anchoring and I think in
every case I've responded by saying no
but this
that is in every case I said well not
that fix but how about this fix and I
think the fixes have been appropriate
yeah yeah I think I often it goes back a
few times but yeah so there has been a
process of collaboration on that level
where this won't work here like this can
we try that I'll say well a wasn't any
good B wasn't any good how about B prime
or C yeah and I think I think probably
that's the way you like to work but
especially with a project like this
where it's not a fixed poem it's it's
also incredibly liberating for me
because you can start writing the music
and see well where I remember something
that came up in this section was it's
not always easy ahead of time I think in
the old days you could plan out the
structure of an opera and say okay I
need a trio here and I need a duet here
and here's we bring everybody in this I
think was more fluid we knew we're
setting up characters and situations but
as I'm writing it you know you say well
here's a place we really do have to have
these people be together we made a
quartet out of what had been part of a
monologue I remember now there was
things that Simon said and we're just
changing a little and we made them you
got a little glimpse of some of the
quite get the quartet but we got a trio
the trio and what it does become a
quartet it right before the close of the
city yeah and when you heard that trio
you were hearing words that I had
originally written for one character
partly because I am a complete beginner
at doing this and it didn't take us long
to turn it into a trio
how long do you think the entire project
will the production be you think oh
you'll wake up and you'll be so lose two
minutes that's not him now you might
have a hard time
our goal is I've done different kinds of
operations only happens when I read your
poem
the goal is to have no intermission so
you know you can't have more than eight
or nine hours something I know it's
probably an hour and a half without a
break is the idea maybe it may be a
little longer MIT's now again now that
we're starting when you look at the text
it reads quickly it's very elegant
beautiful but when you know when you
spend time with it and make these
characters real there's there's a lot
going on and there are a lot of changes
and characters a lot of a lot of
beautiful words that you don't want to
just run through there are links to this
project on the communications forum
website and I ate some time also from
from your own website I think there
probably are so those of you who want to
sort of pursue this a lot more find out
more about this project have you have we
been able to put anything online yet of
the fragments that you've completed no I
haven't haven't wanted to put those
online yet but there's some good text on
the Opera online and pictures and
there's amazing amount of set design
wonderful graphics working on them again
next week so I would say pretty soon
they'll be I actually I'll probably put
up a website on this I don't like
putting excerpts of things that aren't
finished I usually don't like to make
public there's something about
collaboration and it sounds like the
website does dramatize these different
elements that are coming together I'm
thrilled when I first hear the music and
I was thrilled
I saw Alex's set designs and Alex really
is very very good and when I first saw
those walls breathe and when we started
talking about things floating and that
there are ways to do it and that then
this whole it's an organism that is an
expression of this man's consciousness
and then when it goes oh and all goes
out over the audience and it can be done
and the robots can be done layoffs are
yeah we're trying the robots you know
they're not gonna look like a stainless
steel department store dummies they're
not gonna look like Robert the robot or
some post-war Japanese thing they're
largely made out of light and they come
on as one thing
and they have lights and then they
devolve into the separate robots who
will become the characters actually you
didn't say anything about the robot
prologue you know I just that's a pretty
unusual in the robot prologue they say
they come out with the head robot after
they come apart the head robot says or
sings well the human creators did
instruct us human creators back in the
organic age instructed us to perform
this certain times and so we're going to
do it and one of the other robots says
but I don't get it
this thing dead it's so important it's
at like lost data but there's always
data can always be recovered I don't get
it it says it doesn't matter we're going
to do it and then they discuss it and
then they gradually become the singers
were gonna say and you delight it makes
it possible and do that then at the end
after our big finish they read coalesce
but before there being one of the robot
says was that it I I still don't really
understand why we did this
what is that about and your head robot
says I know what you mean but everybody
who participates gets 10,000 human
rights credits and they turn back into
this thanks so there's a backstory that
is partly fill them which is where did
we go where did the human creators go
and what form of quote life and quote is
persisting in the form of these robots
who are performing basically a kind of
ritual as with the origins of drama and
a thing we've arrived that for that is
that when the robots say this to one
another
there'll be super titles where you get
it in English but they're speaking robot
to one another so they say SmartNet in
fandom dork and fastened state written
stood the British to adore and that wine
for Steven for stay Bernard and Jordan
Jordan not in Restless student Devon our
fashion statement and then you're
getting that maybe we should turn you
like this it's actually
very interested so if you I know who
know robot were laughing right the
native robot speakers won't find this
that interesting Todd thank you very
much it looks like a wonderful project
and we thank you for taking part today
thank you here we premiere this in about
two years so we'll let you know come to
Monte Carlo and threaten store it'll
Bend you can see you there
we're going to what we're going to try
to have a conversation for about another
half hour and then we'll open the floor
to general discussion I thought the
conversation would be helpful because we
could cover a number of aspects of
Pinsky's immensely diverse
intimidatingly diverse portfolio and one
of the most important aspects of his
recent work has has been another form of
outreach that i'm sure many of you know
about and Robert and I have talked about
it many times it's it's a I guess it's a
project that he started when he was the
poet laureate and I'll let him describe
it it's the favorite poem project and
we're going to have a clip or two to
show you I invited Americans to write me
a letter or an email saying the title
and author of a poem that the person
writing loved and would be willing to
read for National Archive my advertising
budget was about seven dollars I
received tens of thousands of responses
there is a book for sale outside called
an invitation to poetry it has a DVD in
the back that has about 25 of the video
segments about on which I'm about to
show you a couple and if anybody here
teaches or knows a teacher I really urge
you to buy the book if only for the DVD
I think you'll see what I mean well look
at a couple of the of the segments on
that DVD that is in the back of the back
of the book and yeah why not start with
a sort of a flagship wanted tract
track six these are baby
four-minute three-minute video segments
my name is John Doherty I'm from
Braintree Massachusetts 34 years old and
I'm a construction worker for the Boston
gas company we do outside construction
work providing natural gas for a
residents or businesses so a lot of
digging laying pipelines
that's it live house means all outdoor
work the satisfying thing about the job
is you're working with a dangerous
element really so it's it's important to
be exact and everything you do you
certainly don't want to leave any kind
of a gas leak behind so you know you
have to be careful you have to pay
attention poetry was was definitely
intimidating initially it just looked
like a lot of words and that were out of
order and out of place and did not
belong together and that's that's the
challenge of it it just takes a lot of
reading and rereading to grasp it but
what you do once you come to understand
it you've achieved something so now you
feel good song of myself as a poem that
I probably had a lot of difficulty
understanding the first time and there
were certain lines that caught me and
that I liked and when I got to the very
end of this very long poem the last half
dozen lines so encouraging he in those
last few lines Whitman tells you what
you're thinking he says that you
probably didn't understand what you're
just read but stay with it and you will
and you'll love it and so it felt like
it was speaking directly to me when I
first read it and
keep those lines in mind no matter what
I read now
the connection I feel with while
Whitman's poem song of myself' is not
due to the fact that he talks about
laborers physical labor working outside
and like the common working American
that's a nice touch in it of course but
I enjoyed it for it's it's uplifting
miss its its ability to inspire me and
and see things in life and in everyday
existence that I hadn't noticed before
that I might have taken it for granted
before
sign of myself by Walt Whitman
there is that in me I do not know what
it is but I know it is in me wrenched
and sweaty calm and cool then my body
becomes I sleep I sleep long I do not
know it it is without name it is a word
unsaid it is not in any dictionary
utterance symbol something it swings on
more than the earth I swing on to it the
creation is the friend who's embracing
awakes me perhaps I might tell more
outlines I plead for my brothers and
sisters do you see all my brothers and
sisters it is not chaos or death it is
form union plan it is eternal life it is
happiness
[Music]
the spotted Hawk swoops by and accuses
me he complains at my gavin by loitering
I too am NOT a bit tamed I to him
untranslatable ice on my barbaric yawp
over the roofs of the world the last
Scout of day holds back for me it flings
my likeness after the rest and true as
any on the shadowed wilds it coaxes me
to the vapour and the dusk I depart as
air I shake my white locks at the
runaway Sun I effused my flesh and
Eddie's and drift in lacy Jags I
bequeath myself to the dirt to grow from
the grass I love if you want me again
look for me under your boot soles you
will hardly know who I am or what I mean
but I shall be good health to you
nevertheless and filter on 5eo blood
failing to fetch me at first keep
encouraged missing me one place search
another I stopped somewhere waiting for
you could we see the audience the
filmmaker the filmmakers were
independent producer directors around
the country so we didn't have to pay
transportation costs we brought them
here for a film school and my executive
producer Juanita Anderson told them
about a library of shots what kind of
video they're gonna use lenses and I
talked to them about the project and we
had a favorite poem reading at BU in
which we had a college president and a
grade school kid and a high school kid
and an art director and an elderly
person we had her reading with the kind
of range which we can't demonstrate with
one video but the point is partly a very
great range of people not particularly
poets or professors of poetry Robert
let's talk a little bit about about the
the the Democratic implications of this
I mean clearly one of the implications
of the whole project just to say poetry
should be
we shouldn't think of poetry as a kind
of a lead activity which only professors
and poet tasters like but then it's
something that that ordinary people can
enjoy and an experience that poetry
belongs to everyone but of course there
are plenty of poets who think that this
is sort of selling out we can put it
differently we could say we're
establishing a true a lead of people who
understand the poem have incorporated
can read it aloud in a way that other
people can perceive it against the false
elite of people who get tenure at Yale
or Harvard or bu or somewhere and often
don't know anything about what a poem
actually is so it's a it's a the elitism
is the elitism of people who were
actually responding to a poem in a way
that can be communicated to another
person which is very fundamental to the
art of poetry and it substitutes for a
couple of elites there's the academic
elite which sometimes really not very
close to the nature of the art of poetry
and in our country but the most true
elite in American culture is an elite
based on performers so that instead of
kings and queens and Dukes and Earls and
duchesses we have singers and actors and
athletes this is a great improvement
far better to idealize somebody because
they can throw a ball like hell or
they're beautiful they can sing and
dance very well then because of who
their great great grandparents were but
this is different from either the
academic world or the media world of
celebrity this is an art in which each
individual's the readers body the
readers breath is the medium Walt
Whitman is dead John Doherty is alive
John Daugherty's breath saying those
words by Whitman become Whitman's medium
it's not Whitman being read by an actor
it's not Whitman himself giving a
terrific poetry reading on the poetry
reading circuit it is the readers
realization literal realization of the
poem and yes I think that in a democracy
the idea of an art in which not the
performer but each into an art that is
inherently on a human scale on the scale
of one person I love digital media this
is a digital medium itself but the
medium that is also human and bottling
as in this subject of the Opera there's
a certain respect for that and I think
there are ways you could argue that in a
democracy this ancient art in some race
has non democratic origins courtly
origins has an important function
because it inherently respects what used
to be called the dignity of the
individual do you remember the Jay V
Cunningham poem that talks about
breathes on the words he made sort of an
embodiment of viewer I couldn't quote it
but yes it was a test you were supposed
to be able to quote it the artist is
dead but the readers breath literal or
imaginary because it might not be
reading aloud it might be just hearing
it in your mind's hear that is your
particular pencil
formal possession by the day if John
Dougherty reads that or I'd David reads
the Connie hammer I read a Ben Jonson
that sliver of that original
consciousness is being realized in the
new person's breath but it can it also
be realized rather just in reading why
do I have to read it aloud to reanimate
it poetry is an art that takes for its
material the sounds of a language and if
your is rep and said poetry is a centaur
by which he means in prose you fire an
arrow at a target in poetry you do the
same thing but you're writing a horse at
the same time and the horse I take to be
the human body the bodily part of poetry
so if you're reading a poem and not
hearing it at all as far as I'm
concerned you're missing an important
part of it also true if you're stupid
you won't get it all it is an art of the
mind and of the body and every art that
I can think of in some way uses
something physical music uses physical
sounds film is a physical phenomenon
visually you know or plastic art visual
arts and poetry also has a physical
bodily component and that is the sounds
of the words let's show you one more
fragment from this and then we'll go on
to some other discussion we can come
back to these but could I nominate one
because I think she actually starts
reading right away and I'd rather just
either read could we do number four and
I think I think she actually reads the
poem in the recites the beginning and
the end I think so let's just look at
the recitation in the beginning and not
watch the whole unless you think it's
valuable I thought we would I don't want
to watch only part of one of them I want
to watch the whole alright alright it's
your it's your project I'll go through
with this with this tedious idea go
ahead actually it's a very this is my
favorite of all of thee of all of the in
moving slow
he has no peer you ask him so
for a year I interrupted her the flaw
like Theodore St in moving slow he has
no peer you ask him something in his ear
he thinks about it for a year and then
before he says a word they're upside
down unlike a bird he will assume that
you have heard a most exasperating lug
but should you call his manner smug his
eye and give his branch a hug
then off began to sleep he goes still
swaying gently by his toes and you just
know he knows he knows old she's
actually very charming and at the end of
this fragment she reads it again she
recites it again even more remarkably
she analyzes this that I'd rather hear
Robert than his than his she says that
she likes the line still swaying gently
by his toes he says quite correctly
that's an amount of poetic just used
that word but she says it's like you can
see him swinging there I don't mean to
deprecate the entire academic profession
of the study of literature but it is
true that often you will hear an
extremely celebrated grand profesor
or profesora give a lecture and when the
person reads parts of the poems you
realize the person is not hearing the
poems
this is not incidental or ornamental and
it's not histrionic skill it's not being
an actor these are not trained actors
but it's a little bit like music or
dancing you're either doing it or not I
mean you can tell when some it just is
not not hearing it and so I say that
partly missed
partly to say that it's not all about
democracy or the people there also is
something exacting about art and every
art has its techniques and its demands
and it's it can be quite stringent and
it's not just that it's an acute that a
child or construction workers reading a
poem the things they say about the poems
in every case I think are cogent the the
book prints 200 poems and there's a
quotation from a letter that I got next
to each poem we try to choose things
that were quite illuminating so there's
an aspect of the project I'm happy to
say is a latest as well as clearly an
aspect that it's democratic to I was the
editor I chose which letters I thought
were very good and though the poems
included don't represent my taste
exactly there aren't the poems I would
have chosen could you represent my
standards if a poem was not up to my
standards we didn't put it in an
anthology we didn't make a video of it
Casey at the bat Casey at the bat
perhaps an exception but it's a very
good piece of pop art and the kid does
do it very well well I'm glad you're in
favor of some aspects of pop art I'd
like to make a quick transition we don't
have a lot of time and I want to give
the audience a chance at you but they're
at least two topics that I want us to
talk a little bit about Robert one of
them is what has always struck me as one
of the most remarkable and interesting
things about your career a brief
background when Robert first began to
publish he was immensely influential as
a even as a young poet because he seemed
to be doing something at the time that
was new in quotes in the sense that the
established line in poetry was elsewhere
and what was new essentially was how
deeply conversational his early poetry
was and his first few books of poetry
not only had a kind of conversational
feel but they were but they were and and
and a kind of syntactic coherence that
was close in some respects closer to
prose than it was to poetry although
they were very sort of thought through
and
four poems they were true poems there
was this not exactly prosaic but
conversational dimension to Robert's
early poetry and especially in the in in
the book entitled an explanation of
America as as you've gone on though your
poetry has changed in somewhat radical
ways and in somewhat surprising ways and
there have been some essays written
about this which I've learned from
studying Roberts working at different
stages of his career but to oversimplify
his his work becomes less and less
conversational it becomes harder I think
more difficult sometimes harder to
follow you have to work harder to get
the meaning although I think he's always
an accessible poet and moves toward a
condition in which writing something
closer to incantation than conversation
and there's a deeply sort of encanta
Tory and visionary dimension to his most
recent poetry many people have many
people have commented on this my first
question is do you remember a moment in
your own work when you felt a turning
like that I mean I know of some poems I
might nominate but I was wondering if
you felt a moment where you was changing
it's so hard to write a good poem and
you die not knowing if you ever have I
mean if you want to know that you've
done something right you must become
something like a surgeon or an airline
pilot really seriously then you know you
know you you flew your you you performed
the mission to do with the surgery or
the you know you have a much more
objective measure than if you're an
artist
earlier to the students earlier I quoted
Keats his epitaph that he wrote for
himself paralyzed one whose name was
written water part of him knew or
suspected that he was John Keats that
people like us would be reading his
words hundreds of years later but since
he wasn't a madman he also admitted the
possibility perhaps his life had been in
vain he had not written masterpieces and
when he thought he did to her had it was
a delusion and being a genius he wrote
brilliant epitaph that covers both cases
it's ironic if he is John Keats and it
is a very moving evocation of what it is
to have your name be written water if
not it's so hard to write a good poem
that when you are trying to do it what
you were thinking about is how you can
possibly approach that goal so you're
not thinking about well I've done the
conversational thing I think time to be
a little more incantation image you're
you're much more you're much more like
somebody exactly how I thought it would
trying to change trying to keep an
airplane in the air or trying to save
the patient you know you're just
desperately you know very intensely
trying to make something that works it's
also true that explanation of America is
spoken to it it's and it's spoken
fictionally to a child between the ages
of 8 and 11 and almost because of that
it it's a book-length poem with a little
preparatory poem that is rather
imagistic and is more incantation 'el
and apone at the end that is also much
less conversational and more like a
linear prayer I wasn't consciously
saying look I can do that too but it
seemed an appropriate way to say this is
a little bit like I'm writing a concerto
minor keys are involved another time I
might be writing a song cycle or this
isn't a major key that there is not only
development there's also different tasks
at some point it is true I fell in love
with the substantive and this is I mean
grammatically and this is like talking
about nuts and bolts I had been very
much in love with very complicated
sentences like the first sentence of
George Herbert spomb church monuments
the man is about to go to pray and he
stops in the graveyard outside the
church and he addresses his body and he
says the souls can go and pray now body
little child you'd be good stay out here
and look at this you learned something
from it while that my soul repairs to
her devotion here I into my flesh that
it paid times
may take acquaintance of these heaps of
dust to which the blast of deaths
incessant motion fed by the exhalation
of our crimes drives all at last you
know your diagram and on the blackboard
it's it's a like a spider II thing but
how beautiful the energy is directed
while that my soul repairs her devotion
here I include my flesh that it'd be
times may take acquaintance of these
heaps of dust to which the blast of
deaths incessant motion fed by the
exhalation of our crimes drives all at
last I once asked a lot of doctoral
students at Berkeley what's the main
verb in that sentence some of them said
drives no f it is in isn't it great
everything grows off and tune the
problems called church monuments so part
of oneself technically is in love with
the idea of how much energy syntax
generates and it's taking the rhymes as
it goes and it's taking the line endings
as it goes and then at some point you've
been doing that a lot those long
sentences at some point you know you're
probably thinking about church where the
Southern's is coming with the articles
the yoke the back the needle the treadle
but this is this is one of Roberts most
famous poems it's a prize-winning poem
called shirt maybe I should read it
Robert maybe but why don't you adore
poems but describe it and then readers
subsidy I mean that poem in fact goes
all over the lot intellectually but
things I've read plagiarize a little bit
of a thing here and I have another idea
I got from there but the poem is sort of
dominated by that the sense of
substances in that case with the article
there's an there's a power to that it's
a kind of individuals fragment since he
doesn't want to read it it's a kind of
inventory he would be much more
cooperative if it wasn't his friend it's
what friends are for it's so nice
oh no I mustn't know
[Music]
you know I think he's not behaving well
if he doesn't behave better I'm going to
recite some of his suppressed poetry
that I said to change I said to David
keep enticing tell me a green shirt an
optic and I don't want to begging me to
do it
shirt the back the yoke the yardage
lacked seems the nearly invisible
stitches along the collar turned in a
sweatshop by Koreans or Malaysians
gossiping over tea and noodles on their
break or talking money or politics while
one fitted this arm piece with its
overseen to the band of cuff I button at
my wrist the presser the cutter the
ringer the mangle the needle the Union
the treadle the bobbin the code the
infamous blaze at the triangle Factory
in 1911 146 died in the flames on the
ninth floor no hydrants no fire escapes
the witness in the building across the
street who watched how a young man
helped a girl to step up to the
windowsill then held her out away from
the masonry wall and let her drop and
then another as if he were helping them
up to enter a streetcar and not eternity
a third before he dropped her put her
arms around his neck and kissed him then
he held her into space and dropped her
almost at once he stepped to the sill
himself his jacket flared and fluttered
up from his shirt as he came down air
filling up the legs of his great rousers
like heart cranes bedlamite shrill shirt
ballooning wonderful how the pattern
matches perfectly across the placket and
over the twin bar tacked corners of both
pockets like a strict rhyme or a major
chord prints plaids
checks houndstooth Paterson Madras the
clan Parkins invented by new owners
inspired by the hoax of ocean to control
their savage Scottish workers tamed by a
fabricated heraldry MacGregor Bailey
mcmartin the kilt devised for workers to
wear among the dusty clattering looms
Weaver's Carter's spinners the loader
the doctor the Navi the planter the
picker the sorter sweating at her
machine in a litter of cotton as slaves
in calico head rags sweated in fields
george herbert your descendant is a
black lady in south carolina
her name is Irma and she inspected my
shirt its color and fit and feel and
it's clean smell have satisfied both her
and me we have called its cost and
quality down to the buttons of simulated
bone the buttonholes the sizing the
facing the characters printed in black
on neck band and pair the shape the
label the labor the color the shade the
shirt
the later palms become even more
visionary and we may have a chance to
look at those who later but I want to
make a transition to the final topic
we'll discuss before we open to the to
general discussion and then as this look
recent prose book that robert has
written called the life of david i've
read it closely and been deeply moved by
it and it strikes me that one of the
interesting things about the book it is
like a vast Pinsky poem that is to say
it's full of disparate energies that
seem to sort of create at least the
illusion of an absence of coherence but
when you finally when you finish the
whole you realize how richly coherent it
is and it is in some degree a kind of
departure for a poet like Robert Pinsky
to turn to this sort of a book it's a I
thought with that first Robert I might
ask you to sort of in just a general way
describe how you why you felt that David
was such a fascinating figure what why
he mattered to you in a way I've tried
to unite the two subjects the previous
subject in this one syntax and poetry is
the equivalent of melody in music it
connects things over time it's the
equivalent perhaps of harmonic structure
but even more of melody so that any good
syntax is in some sense conversational
that it converts and it's between so
that sometimes when people are talking
they talk and rather like wow that my
soul repairs the devotion here my stomer
fuscus at the time stood and there are
other times when it is more also
conversation when it's no hydrants no
fire escapes Yeats says in a letter it
is the syntax of in memoriam that is
odious it is the language of no man when
moved our teacher winter says somewhere
else about poetry doesn't like something
one would never say moving in a certain
way on some level it has to seem like
some even if the person were muttering
it to themselves it's what connects part
to part and to say no hydrants no fire
escapes is to emphasize minimal
connection
and to say wow that my soul repair
stores here item if that connects
suggests very very almost in prepping
elaborate hypo tactic and paratactic
syntax are the rhetorical terms the
David book is in a way about being
Jewish it's about what is a Jew and Jews
through an historical destiny are highly
syncretic you might even say synthetic a
sense of synthesis and connecting one
thing to another thing it's been said
one of the things people say about Jews
is if you go to Chile or you could go to
Romania or if you go to Alabaman and
Obama the most Chilean chili a nose are
the Jews that they are extremely
adaptable in some sense so that in this
country Irving Berlin who was born in
Russia and had a longer name than Berlin
at one point wrote white Christmas and
having succeeded at that he also wrote
Easter Parade David for interesting
reasons we can speculate about rather
than Abraham is the quintessential hero
of these people neighbor ham is the
father he's the first Joe David his some
of the rabbi's say is he reading Jewish
she said among the Jews his great
grandmother was Ruth a Moabite woman my
chapter about Goliath is titled to
cousin Goliath I point out with the
light in the last chapter that the six
pointed star is of David only by the
most imaginative process he never if
there was an actual person there it
wasn't until really what they now call
early modern Europe wasn't there like
1415 century that that symbol of six
pointed star was connected with Jews
it's a great symbol the two triangles
the male dagger pointing to the sky
embraces the earth the sea males chalice
open to the sky points to the earth
so it's a yin-yang symbol and david ii
is all of the above he's a great killer
he's a great poet he's an artist he's a
politician
he's a terrible person he's a great
person he has this he connects many
things he is very disparate and just as
one is interested technically in all the
many many ways that one word is
connected to another word all the
varieties of syntax it no two
grammatical junctions are exactly the
same even if you write a line like
tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow and
tomorrow each and in each tomorrow has a
slightly different character each
juncture is a slightly different
juncture because the pressure of
repetition varies through the course of
the line and just as one might be
fascinated by all the infinite range of
grammatical junctures and connections
one is interested in the yin and yang
the inclusive could I do that dagger
chalice thing right
females chalice points this earth the
male dagger points to the sky yeah okay
it is all of the above the colony of
David to be all of the above the Pali
the Jews to be all the above are related
in my line mind to the ambition of
writing a kind of poetry in which
anything can be included well the the
David book it's perhaps less capacious
than some of the poems because not
everything is included it relevant but
it is a kind of very imaginative
retelling of the David story that goes
beyond the Bible in some respects I
thought maybe you should you might
mention something about some of the
other homework you did when you were
working on the book it was so easy to do
the homework because Louie Ginsberg
compiled this great great compilation
called the legends of the Jews it's all
the crazy weird Midrash is all of the
stories and he arranges it by character
so also there are things about David or
right there and they are many and
they are very very weird the one that
I'll tell them quickly the one that
epitomizes what I just said about
inclusiveness David was not supposed to
live his full 70 years as he did his
original destiny was to die as an infant
but Adam happened to be walking around
in the part of heaven where the souls
are waiting to be born
he saw David's soul and said wow that's
a great soul that that kid has been hey
that Saul should die oh he should have a
whole life fortunately God is in that
part of heaven too and David and their
and boy to be born in Adam says to God
that that kid should have a whole he's
that's a great fault you you gave me a
thousand years to live
I'll give him 70 of my years so God
calls up the lawyer angels they write up
a contract the undersigned Adam does
hereby believer the year from and David
gets live oh well this is Adam who's the
seed all the potential good and bad and
glorious and various things that we can
do he's he's the seed of all of us and
he recognizes the soul that is all of
the above so he's all of the above and
sin potential he recognizes the life
that has come closest to the fruition or
flowering of everything that a person
might be and that's not biblical that's
some Manik rabbi and made that up it's
it's sir it's certainly it's it's it's
certainly a book that will surprise you
even if you have no interest in the
Bible or in David you'll find this a
remarkable book and there's a turning at
the end that I think we could conclude
on I'd like to ask you Robert to read
the very end of the book because do you
have a copy if you need it there there
is a very little hint of an
autobiographical dimension to the book
and unlike many of Roberts poems which
always have at least a kind of hint of a
of a personal engagement but the
autobiographical element emerges with a
star
clarity and Moo and poignant at the very
end of the book and that's the part of
the book that I'm asking Robert to look
here okay David is more enigmatic than
any purely Christian or Jewish paradigm
more tangled at the roots and more
proliferating larger an enduring story
of stories necessarily involves quirks
and guises a paradoxical incrustation of
Midrash for example the six-pointed
figure known as the Star of David was
pretty certainly unknown to David though
Gregory Peck where's the image on his
tunic in David and Bathsheba the six
pointed star was not associated with the
King David nor with Jews until more than
a thousand years after the time of David
the star is of David the Psalms are of
David the very stories in the Hebrew
Bible and in the legends are of David or
of him by sovereign possessive force of
attribution beyond scholarly
demonstration and there are different
ways and degrees all rotating around
David's genitive central energy that
attracts and embraces them in the Roman
Forum on the triumphal arch of the
emperor Titus celebrating his capture
and destruction of Jerusalem a
millennium after its founding the
branched candelabrum appears but not the
anachronistic star is not mentioned in
the Bible nor in the Talmud nor in the
rabbinical literature the first Jewish
source to mention the stars in the 13th
century of the Common Era symbol doesn't
appear to be much used before the 15th
century the Jewish encyclopedia says it
probably was the Kabbalah that deprived
the symbol from the Templars I'll skip
the paragraph I've already paraphrased
to you about the male dagger and the
female chalice the star of David's
history has been far from uniformly
sweet when the Portuguese monarch Afonso
for reserved it reversed his
predecessors benign policies all Jews
were forbidden to appear in public
without a visible six-pointed yellow
star on their hat or coat in this regard
the Nazis again appear as not
originators but copiers adapters
exploiters and refiners
continuing and extending the theme of
inclusion Gershom Scholem and his essay
on the star commends the wisdom of
converting the symbol of oppression into
an insignia of national identity on the
flag of Israel and as a glyph
unmistakable as the cross the stringent
geometry of the star in the way of human
makings accepts but transfigures it's
range of meanings here is a particular
instance a photograph of 12 young men
taken in the bad year 1939 sewn onto
their uniforms is that six-pointed star
of interlocked triangles said to be
borrowed from a device of the Knights
Templar and incorporated without
rabbinic approval into the agonized
mysticisms and paedon trees of Kabbalah
the young men squinting back at the
camera are named ralph bender joseph
siegel nathan schneider Morris Newberg
Herman Schneider Gilbert Kaplan Harry
Silver David Becker Milton silver
Milford
Pinsky Abraham ball and Seymour Barron
they are the Jewish aces in shorts knee
pads and basketball shoes one of them
holds a basketball on which someone has
painted City champs 1938 1939 another
cradles the trophy with its crowning
figure of an athlete holding the ball
overhead in the trophy makers stylized
gesture of attainment and plated metal
they are standing in front of their high
school in Long Branch New Jersey 1939
the group picture is an interesting
artifact because of the apparent wacky
or tragic incongruity of that
six-pointed emblem deployed in Europe
for such different purposes far more
like those of King Afonso at the moment
the photograph was taken the players of
the Jewish aces were most likely far
from unaware of the laws and measures
enacted by the third ray
some of them would eventually go into
battle against that regime it seems safe
to assume also that on that Sunday
afternoon in Long Branch beaming at the
camera the young men were aware of the
assertive maybe even defiant quality of
the team's name the Jewish faces the
implications of aces superior raffish
primary sensual worldly singular or lone
victorious adept also fit David in such
impure fluid partly accidental
manifestations certain human doings
continued as nodes of energy durably
complex particles that really shift and
recombine to exceed likelihood and evade
prediction King David like the
six-pointed design he would not have
recognized gathers meaning in assistant
Lee and diastole of need and invention
over centuries of attainment and outrage
suffering an ordinary life in an
endlessly glamorous stubborn accretion
floor is open to questions comments
responses of various kinds yes can you
come to the microphone because we're the
event is being recorded and we want to
hear what everyone has to say I can
repeat questions to if others don't try
to do them that the answer to my
question is already contained in some of
your remarks but I wanted to know if you
could comment on the importance of the
human voice as the medium of poetry when
you first launched the favorite poem
project I started to thinking about what
my
home might be and all of the poems that
originally came to my mind were poems
that I had memorized as a child
now did I memorize them because they
were my favorites or did they become my
favorites because I memorize them I
don't know but you were talking about
you know the voice as being kind of an
an embodiment or maybe a reimburse
pirita might say or spirits a good word
because it means breath and latin okay
of say the Whitman poem and you know
especially at a moment in history where
we're shifting our media and you know
technology you know poetry was
originally spoken I believe and I just
wanted to know if you could talk about
voice and poetry the human voice the
spoken voice an important distinction
for me is that it is a vocal art so not
necessarily a performative art and in a
culture where as I've said performance
is so central it's a very important
distinction when you memorize those
poems you incorporated them you took
them into your body quite literally you
know isn't that the Bradbury novel where
certain people have memorized certain
poems that person's body is that book
the poem in my opinion is something that
happens it takes place each time someone
reads it it is like a piece of music it
happens each time it's been there's a
notation that represents it but it is
something that happens in the course of
a certain amount of time it takes place
it takes place in a literal or imagined
voice so the vocality is not an ornament
it is not part of as show business as a
category of show business poetry will
always be kind of cute trivial as an art
its immense and central and its
nature is vocal its intellectual as well
as in the pound metaphor of the center
but it is also essentially vocal and I
really do
I suppose I'm promoting my product but
the DVD you've only gotten a glimpse of
it the DVD that is in that book
invitation to poetry is for me I can't
tell you how glad I am that teachers can
get it to me it's a great teaching tool
the teacher can show the kids not a tape
of a professor talking about the palm or
Sir John Gielgud reading Shakespeare or
even a rap artist doing a skillful for
the poet with a great personality it's
anyone at all who loves the poem and
that to me is very important in the
nature of the art I encourage you to
sort of meditate your questions raise
your hands when you're ready while we're
waiting for more energy from the
audience I have a question you mentioned
Eve or winters a little while ago Robert
and he was certainly the most compelling
teacher I ever experienced and Robert
and I were at Stanford together in a
period when this astonishing poet critic
was a very important influence on anyone
who came within a hundred miles of
Stanford I wonder if you talked a little
bit about winters and how you see him
now from in many ways Europe your career
is not congenial to what winters might
have imagined for you I think it's
necessarily true
I remember one time that another teacher
we had both fight for a wonderful man
about the 18th century described reading
applications with winters and Budd
Pfeiffer said I I thought I was gonna
please him his intellectual side and I
said huh look at this woman she says the
main part of poetry for her is the sense
of the words and when she said that's
pretty much right
I had 500 I guess I guess and what I
remember very well as winters really
particularly in French very beautiful he
had a rather beautiful voice he said
about his own work and poetry what I did
was small but good and he broke
beautiful little pun this is upon by
ivor winters a summer commentary when I
was young with sharper sense the
farthest insect cry I heard could stay
me through the trees intense
I watched the hunter and the bird where
is the meaning that I found
or was it but a state of mind some old
penumbra of the ground ground in which
to be but not to find now summer grasses
brown with heat have crowded sweetness
through the air the very roadside dust
is sweet
even the unshadowed earth is fair the
soft voice of the nesting dove and the
dove and swift erratic flight like a
rapid hand within a glove caressed the
silence and the light beautiful last
answer amid the rubble the Fallen fruit
fermenting in its rich dk smears brandy
on the trampling boot and sends it
sweeter on its way amid the rubble the
Fallen fruit fermenting in its rich
decay smears brandy on the trampoline
and sends it sweeter on its way that
sense of scale and it's a very beautiful
and David and I were fortunate to study
with a real artist who's also very
learning man I think his work lived I
think people still other celebrity
critics at the time seemed to me
absolutely for God and Ivan only I
remember there was someone named Clint
Brooks well I think winters people are
still quoting him and arguing with him
and he did leave write those poems that
are terrific not great great poet
his emphasis was very powerful
irrationalist his great collection of
critical writings was called in defense
of reason and he was often complained
against for emphasizing the rationale so
intensely that the emotional dimension
of poetry was given according to these
complaints in inadequate acknowledgement
in winters account I take it you don't
agree Robert he was very irritated by
some of his adherence remember he may
have been the one who asked him but what
he made it affect so many nuns came to
study with him it took his courses and
he did look very Jason what in the world
they think I'm saying he was you know he
had his blindnesses but he did not just
say the poems were only rational no he
was very interested in the interplay
between things I've been talking to you
about
he had his limitations I'm proud to say
that David and I were not amongst the
robots
we were willing to arguing with him that
there was a lot to be said in behalf of
Yeats as compared to disturbs more right
while others were just saying yeah ok
ste thirds more greater one of the
things Robert and I did when we were in
graduate school Wheatley Winters was
famous for making obiter dicta judgments
of poets he disliked so he would say
things like Wordsworth is a minimum is a
marginal figure and he would often he
would often choose you know iconic
figure he'd say Shakespeare's sonnets
are not what they're cracked up to be he
would say things like that
and he would and he would also also
celebrate or or or argue for poets no
one had ever heard of often with
ridiculous names from very comical names
like Barnaby guj and that laid crap sea
was another one of the poets that
winters went just defended and at one
point because we were sort of arrogant
graduate students Robert and I
collaborated on a parody of winters in
which I wrote the prose and Robert wrote
all the poetry and it was a it was a
sort of fake winters essay in which
in which we created in which we created
a typical winters poet who was virtually
unknown I think
well you looked at Jonah's very that's
thrown is very with one of the colonial
discoveries and Jones very wrote songs
and poems so one of our one of winters
say darkness very very early 18th
century American poet named I've learned
since it's actually pronounced Jonas
berry but it's Jones very if you see it
spell and Jones very was one of winters
his great discoveries and amongst other
he had couplets at the bottom of the
page on his poems and one of the couples
was I now I'll read it in the winters
voice I know repose my weary head upon
my pillow but I shall be shortly gone a
little blue me and our poet was called
Smith extremely and Robert wrote a
series of comical little poems I wish I
had the text here the paraphrase the
rational paraphrase of all of the poems
one was a sonic eligible in all forms
and all of them basically said I put a
sieve this roll into my lunchbox
i I wish I could find this manuscript I
think it would be worth something now
because of Roberts but the only one we
remember is the couplet I now insert a
seedless roll into my lunchbox but I
shall be shortly through
[Applause]
so I remember reading this to another
colleague of a from a professor that we
both like very much a great a great man
in his own right who had been a student
of winters himself albert gerard and
gerard loved this parody but he warned
us never to let winter see it and to my
knowledge he never saw it we were so
scared that all all copy there are no
extant copies
unless you've been high I have one but I
can't find question okay then you'll be
sick suffering the question is why in
this day in the age in the English
language is there no rhyme and anymore
you're not the only person to have that
misapprehension I think that Joseph
Brodsky who wrote so many awful poems in
English also had that notion that he was
the only one writing in rhyme and meter
many people do some very well phangan
wrote great poems wonderful poems
beautiful elegy for his brother in poem
inviting as his brothers suffer Tom
wrote beautifully in couplets he is only
one example so it's not the case you
know I David's been talking about an
explanation for America I broke my neck
writing that poem in iambic pentameter
and the shirt poem that I read to you
sure is also in the measure of I am big
pentameter and rhyme in English was not
it was considered vulgar by writers like
Milton because the classical languages
didn't rhyme so it's a more complicated
question than it appears to be and the
fact that there are a lot of people who
writing free-verse badly not really
verse at all shouldn't obscure the fact
it's possible to write rhyme and meter
quite badly too I'm afraid
it all depends yes sir as a practitioner
of maybe the most humanistic of the arts
the poetry you've just finished an opera
about a man who wants to be a robot and
it's introduced by robots
does that horrify you the idea that
someone would wish to be a machine do
you think that the robots will ever be
able to write poetry the same way that
humans would the character in the
characters mind he's doing the opposite
of becoming a machine he's freeing
himself from the fungible mortal machine
of the body
he's leaving matter he thinks he's
becoming pure spirit and the word robot
as I understand it is a Czech word
originally it means worker thing that
works in that sense we all aspire to be
robots we always to get our work done
this is one of the great human pleasures
I don't think it's that simple
I do want very much with that story to
raise questions like the questions
you're asking whether I mean there are
characters I'd make a joke of it in the
Opera but they're all so serious there
are characters three characters named
the United Nations the United Way and
the administration come to Simon and say
what about the starving of the earth
what about people who are suffering
you've already upset the world economy
by putting all your resources into this
project and in this script it does say
there is a pageant a parade of the
starving and suffering of the earth
people who don't have enough to eat or
water people have terrible diseases
children and there's we somehow put that
on stage I don't know how we put it on
stage it's more almost more of a social
question as a philosophical one in the
Opera I'm not unaware of the question
but I wouldn't boil it down to he oh he
wants to become a robot I didn't I was
very interested by the idea of robotics
very interested by the idea of being of
thinking machines and of this idea that
we are evolving away from the human
container for Intel that intelligence
itself will evolve into some other
format let's say
and I didn't want to make a trite
Frankenstein story out of it I didn't
want to say yet again oh you're
overweening it will come to a bad end I
wanted to make it more ambiguous than
that and the daughter character has a
very she's very ambivalent about this
and she has a strong social conscience
and many misgivings and all through
including the bit your hair here it
quotes uh the quotes that wonderful Mae
Swenson poem body my horse my hound what
will I do who will I be and she says
well how will I remember without my
forgetting how I live without my desk
and I think those are important
questions but I don't want to answer
them in a way that is merely humanistic
in some facile way so it's it's it's
it's smoky yes sir we have in the
frontier two things by way of
introduction to my question I want to
cover what you just said from my limited
knowledge robot is a Czech word that was
popularized if not invented by Karel
Capek
and how you are anyway that's beside the
point the question I had you kind of
threw me off David I don't know your
last name professor this is David I'm
sorry okay you said that dr. Pinsky's
David was a point of departure for him I
think those are your words as though he
was creating something new for himself
I take mouthed exception and I could be
wrong I think you may be right because I
mean it agree with you and dr. Pinsky's
poem about a longish poem about daniel
okay I see a lot of biblical at Harrah's
and yet a certain personal creativity of
his own building on what the Bible
offers about Daniel and you know giving
it a lot more a lot more cloth and also
in something as
spirit a precursor from that is his poem
about the Child Jesus and so I those two
getting hangs together if you will I
think they both form a precursor to the
current David completely from the
childhood of Jesus is a model from the
David book and it's based on the infancy
Gospel of Thomas in other parts of the
apocryphal book of Thomas and the idea
of Apocrypha the idea of Midrash those
are brilliant interesting ideas to me it
seems to me that retellings read actions
improvisations at what point is the star
get attached to it what point of the
songs get attached to him in what way
Jesus and his tellings becomes rather a
brat unlike in the Christian scriptures
we see him between infancy and
adolescence and he's a very difficult
child who only Joseph has authority over
him
this human quality of retelling of
giving another version seems to me one
of the many points of nexus between art
and human behavior art is not its
artists continuous with things that
people do all day we make little mini
works of art famously in our dreams but
when you're trying to be amusing to
someone in a phone conversation or when
friends try to have fun at a party when
you choose colors for your living room
or when you we do our grooming adorn our
little works of art and a character like
Daniel or Jesus or David the biblical
part is only a part of all the
tremendous and crustacean of human
thought and feeling that it's built
around that thing and it's deeply human
and I'll I'm endlessly interested in
that phenomenon and yeah I think of my
book about David as being a stone that I
add to this huge human monument or all
the things to people the movies the
Midrash is to come
I raise the attacks did the bizarre
exculpation people invented for the
terrible things he does as to Uriah the
Hittite
so certain number of scholars make up
absolutely bizarre stories and theories
- you know Uriah the Hittite looks like
a straight our nice guy in the BA but
really yeah he had the key to Goliath's
armor and Goliath was caruth-reilly
David couldn't cut his head off goes to
the armor so Uriah said well I have the
key but I'll give you the key if you
give me a beautiful Israelite bride so
he wasn't entitled to Bathsheba anyway
it's hard to believe that some of these
sages were not did not have any access
to marijuana that is all part of the
process of retelling and telling again
and bringing out the nefarious and
sinister aspects of the story a story's
as great as these read us Jesus reads us
David reads us each telling reads
whoever reads it that's what I mean by a
story of stories and I'm very interested
in that process with the book reads you
then you read the book back and forth
endlessly way back say it's 2070 we'll
have to be public survives with a poet
laureate be propped up by structure or
by subject its 2070 by structure you're
talking about aesthetic structure I'm
talking about some social structure
exactly I'm talking about the structure
the format of one's the structure of
one's work for me it will begin with the
human body is there is is there a way
that someone will want to say again the
words to another person made I chose to
say you words that winters put together
I chose this afternoon to put words say
words that frank O'Hara and a Thomas
Nash put together the 20th and in the
16th century my strongest
mission is that a hundred years from now
some woman who study English in Tanzania
or Ogando or Belize or Thailand will
choose to say words that I put together
and in 2070
I think poet laureate is not important
it's just a sort of a it's a title but
if there is a poet who as I have gotten
inspiration from frank O'Hara Emily
Dickinson Iver winters whatever the
things are I've read I'm hoping that
it's the center I'm hoping that boat
that the person looks around has
feelings and says I'm gonna I'm gonna
express these feelings by the sounds of
the words and if I'm one of the models
that's much more important than poet
laureate use the microphone so I was
wondering do you feel that hardness
first of all have you ever had a period
that was like that and do you feel that
that hardness has to do with you
personally with the kind of work that
you're trying to make or what the
question has to do with my saying that
it's also hard to write a good poem and
the questioner rightly points out that
some poets have said found it easy or
the times in a career when people find
it easy
frank O'Hara said I like to play the
typewriter after breakfast for an hour
or so
it's like this you have to climb a
mountain find your way through a maze
get to the field that has a tree in it
you climb up to the top of the tree and
you wait for a thunderstorm then it's
easy once you're hit by lightning it's a
computer game to get hit by lightning to
get hit by lightning once you're hit by
lightning no problem I'm hit by
lightning but you go through a lot of
schools rube before you can get there
and you know you listen to listen to
that famous thing where Illinois Jacquet
played flying home at the Newport Jazz
Festival and it sounds like it sounds so
exciting and it also sounds like he just
he's breathing he's having sex he's
eating he's just doing something you
know no problem he had to learn to play
this major minor scales and all keys he
you know you don't pick up a saxophone
and just blow it he study he understands
the harmonic structure of that rather
simple blues like harmonic structure
chord chord progression a lot goes you
work real hard to get to where it's easy
the related aspect to that question that
struck me as you were talking the
comment that you made one Robert was
commissioned to write a poem about 9/11
by the Washington Post
it's a beautiful poem and it was
reprinted in one of the best American
poems of whatever year it was and the
poets are asked to make a comment in it
and Roberts comment was interesting
because he says people because this was
an assignment people think this was hard
then you say not really talk about that
you say you know people are surprised by
this got me on some occasions it's fun
to say that it's very hard to write a
good palm
on some occasions it's fun to say it's
not hard I I used to say people would
talk about translating the inferno and I
would say translation
is it's easy because it's impossible if
you try and do something impossible it's
a light-hearted Enterprise because you
know there's no such thing an assignment
people so it must be difficult to write
to assign in a way an assignment gives
you the freedom of saying got to do this
and there's something a little bit
liberating right it's like I used the
same word where that I often find a
can't word the word in the brain I used
them when I talked about working with
Todd one of the human beings enjoyed
difficulty very much and when you're
doing the video game or playing golf or
basketball or tennis or you're working
on a new knitting pattern or building a
boat software you're figuring out here
solving a problem at work you get to a
point where it's neither difficult nor
easy it's just what you want to be doing
and it's hard to remember to eat or go
to the bathroom because you just want to
be doing that and I think that is one of
the most desired human states and that
engaging a worthy difficulty difficulty
worthy of yourself and I said that about
that poem and in recent weeks in
corresponds with somebody who wrote an
essay about the poem I've been revising
it ever since I think I may finally have
it right at one point I took it out of
my book because frankly I felt that you
know the I have to find out which polish
poet it is Adam Zucker yeskey quoted as
saying during the Soviet years the most
ambitious poet was the state they wanted
to control all the metaphors and I felt
that I felt quite frankly I I hate but I
feel like gonna be preaching to the
choir or something I don't want this to
be a big line but I felt that the Bush
administration had so much taken over
9/11 that my poem had changed and that I
was unhappy I was not happy to think
that
that the meaning of my poem is gonna
somehow accede to the use of this as a
really prosperous political slogan like
invading a country that had nothing to
do with it mowers fighting back back we
suspected people yeah that it I I have
gone through agony over that bomb which
I you remind me I said in print it was
easier to write I've never spent so long
revising a poem and frankly the woman
would the woman said about it described
just the poem I want to have written and
included the ambiguity and she she felt
I was going crazy which could be true I
have revised the poem I provides the
constant look the post version is
different from the best American poetry
but version the version that's been in
my manuscript that took that bad and
it's different she this woman who wrote
this beautiful let's say about my poem I
emailed her the latest revision which
incorporates a lot of Katherine Lee
Bates as America the Beautiful near the
end I haven't heard she's been very
afraid of me so I don't know what she
may be right or fight of her she may be
right she may be right one of the really
remarkable things about Robert I mean
there many things about him I admire but
he published a Pullman in New Yorker a
couple of years ago and I wrote him an
email about it saying I didn't
understand one part of it and he wrote
back saying it bothers me a lot that
this poem is not accessible and he was
engaged in a process of revision and
they sent me some change so do you think
this is any better I'm not sure that the
poem was really improved by his changes
but but I know that the poem became
clearer because of his changes and it
seems to be a very meaningful comment on
his way of working that it matters to
him to be understood and I thought maybe
I know that you don't like to do this
because in your position you have to be
friendly to all forms of poetry but
there really is a situation in the
poetry world at large in which there is
a vast ocean of material that's being
written is written in a kind of mystical
or obscurantist way in which no rational
reader can make sense of it I'm
wondering if you would be willing to say
something about sort of the condition of
power
tree in that way I think I think what
never knows what the condition of poetry
is you know the day that Elizabeth
Bishop wrote at the fish houses which I
consider a great poem it didn't say the
next day or the next week or so in Time
magazine New York Times or in poetry
magazine last week Elizabeth Bishop
wrote at the fish houses one of the best
problems in the last 3040 years you
perceive these things over time and
there's a moment at which Stephen
Vincent Benet is a very important poet
and Elizabeth Bishop isn't and then
decades passed and it becomes recast so
you don't know you don't see the scene
well I do know that for many very young
people there is an available style
that's very opaque and you can see why
it is attractive because in this opacity
you seem to be tormented profound
dissatisfied with the limitations of
language and it's an armor against go
Cherie
it's an armor against seeming naive it's
an instant access to sophistication and
it's a to effective defense you perfect
a way of writing that seems to solve all
problems and this was true some winters
disciples who wrote skill will must
crusts that also is a kind of a defense
and I think that to do an art you need
to be vulnerable especially when you're
young you need to be gauche how can you
ever get further if you don't manifest
your go Cherie and so you think it's
pure so it's protective Robert yeah I
think so I think you can see why
especially when there's lots and lots of
people want to write poetry which is a
good thing but then they're afraid of
being klutzy you I know that terror very
well myself and if there's an available
style that protects you against seeming
clumsy or unsure uncertain it's a great
deterrent temptation very attractive
I think you must risk seeming stupid and
I feel it every time I write that I am
risking see me
stupid self Saturday and whatever bad
thing you're worried about banal you
know I I was excessively defensive when
this gentleman asked me about the
humanistic meaning of this vibe because
I'm thinking on the one hand do I wanted
to glibly say we must be humanists and
not the robots on the other hand or I
want to make two you can see that in
either way there's a there's a pitfall
and you have to confront your own
ambivalence and believe me it's much
worse for me than for a 20 year old 19
or 20 year old kid writes something
stupid so it's 90 I you know you wrote
something stupid I write something
stupid Robert Penske wrote
something stupid so if anybody at all is
heard of you the stakes go up and if you
don't feel any of that for me anyway I
know you're right that there are times
when you say it's easy but you have to
feel some of that and I think that all
styles of the period probably always
have an element in them of here's a way
to seem to have done and right now it's
a way to see not to have it's a way to
defend yourself very easy very veiled
instant sophistication we've got that
read very much and you can seem could
sophisticated by adopting this manner is
that okay that was good it wasn't it
wasn't exactly an answer to the question
David Thorburn store was but we wouldn't
know we need enough we need there we
were the two guys at Stanford the two
guys at Stanford from New Jersey
he had gone to Princeton icon to Rutgers
and they actually got us mixed up a lot
I've been very proud of this most of my
life people would confuse it we didn't
look particularly alike sad but we were
the two smart guys from New Jersey or
something and they were mostly
Westerners and one day I was stopped at
a traffic light in my car and a carful a
convertible full of fellow graduate
students pulled up and as the light was
changing
one of the women in the car was very
close to me looked at me and said well
hello mr. la reine Thorburn well I can't
top that story actually I do have a
story about our confusion though it
didn't mean maybe it does top it well
when we when we cared that when we came
out of graduate school we went for
interviews at various places this is an
impossible situation for contemporary
academics to imagine but there were
hundreds of jobs available we were there
we were very sought after we were
offered many jobs the University of
Chicago offered me a job which I turned
down to go to Yale the University of
Chicago called Robert and offered him a
job and they said to him it was Harvard
they called a called Robert and they
said to Robert well you can have this
job we'd like you to come there to write
about my dissertation topic Harvard was
confusing I got a letter from you so he
refused them on this space it was IQ to
come here and among other things we'd
like you to teach one of your favorite
subjects perhaps Conrad in the sea tale
which I had purchased by fit which was
my dissertation this reinforced what
winters said to me winters said don't
take the job at Yale or at Harvard those
faces are traps for young people and
then when I read the Conrad thing I said
maybe he's right so now I can say people
so you teach your Harvard right I say no
my only relation to Harvard because I
want to turn to job down it is a it's
actually probably a rare a group of
people who can say they turned the job
down for at Harvard and then people who
have accepted jobs that's an impressive
thing Robert Robert what am I almost my
credentials one one of one of Roberts
most remarkable credentials well I I
think well I I there was a poem of
Roberts I was hoping to have him read at
a conclusion so a couple more questions
if there are any and then I I think I'd
like Robert do you have copies of the
chat book with you I how'd you do pretty
dude or sure okay any final questions or
comments there's a the the chat book
that is about to appear
in a month or two your question here yes
and I've been watching our culture well
forever or my version forever fifty
three years and but I've really noticed
over the last 15 to 20 years
what an odd way and I think it's not all
anglo-saxon cultures I think it's
particularly American this very weird
relationship we have with memory
actually I'm struck by more our
relationship to forgetting and I just
wondered if you could speak to that
because the when you said or you
described the moment when someone's
words have impacted you enough that you
want to say those same words again
that's a moment that I recognize in my
life not just from reading but I
remember specific moments hundreds of
them when my brother or a friend said
something that was so perfect that I've
repeated it a hundred times and it's
it's part of the meaning fullness of my
own life and I feel at the same time I
look around me and get the feeling that
I'm in a culture that's desperate to
forget as much as it can and obliterate
as much as it can and I can't quite pull
that all together and I'm wondering how
you do I thought of I thought of calling
my new manuscript the book of forgetting
and line and one of the poems has to do
with forgetting being a form of memory
forgetting is a particularly disturbing
form of memory I'm going to in response
to your question I'm going to read a
poem other than one David wanted me to
read I'll read the other one as well oh
gosh are we I'll read both this is a
poem that is probably at the far end of
being hard to understand for some of my
friends I'm still not sure what I'm
going to entitle it it's this phenomena
of things being forgotten
poor Bert Williams WC Fields that he
can't her all those early comics the
Ziegfeld comic said the most inventive
the best writer the best performer was
Bert Williams Bert Williams was a black
man he could only work in blackface he
tried working without the blackface he's
a rather light-skinned black man and it
didn't work for him though it was not a
demeaning characters characters you can
on the web you can pick up things like
you can you can buy him singing his song
nobody when I'm in trouble I know that
how I can rely on
nobody anyway he's just one example and
cultural forgetting as well as personal
forgetting is something I'm interested
in and I think in a first draft his
problems call I've never heard of one of
my friends suggested calling it but it's
now the title Louie Louie but probably a
lot of people under a certain age even
have forgotten Louie Louie and it's that
phenomena and then there are expressions
people forget how many people here have
ever heard the expression white Catholic
one person how many people have ever
heard the expression white June nobody
you can guess what they mean though
right
somebody who seems more like a wasp but
they happen to be Jewish or Catholic I
was at Notre Dame when I heard white Jew
since I was a child at Notre Dame I was
talking to a kid who explained that his
parents were on the board of the
symphony in the Midwestern city he came
from and he said I'm what you call a
white Catholic that is it's not a
working-class family it's a very young
tennis playing kind of family I'll read
this poem that I read the poem toward
the Diddy's that's okay I've heard of
black Irish but I never heard of white
Catholic or white Jew I have heard of
his poetry popular but I never heard of
Lawrence Welk Grove Sid Caesar off
television
I had heard of Kwanzaa but I have never
heard of Burke Williams I have never
heard of Will Rogers or Roger Williams
or Buck Rogers or Pearl Buck or Frank
Bucket Yale or Frank buck or Frank
Merriwell at Yale I had heard of Yale
but I never heard of George W Bush I
have heard of Harvard but I never heard
of numerus clausus which sounds to me
like some kind of pig latin how many
people here know what numerus clausus is
- he's a secret number that until a
couple of decades ago the secret
percentage of jubie's jews that were
allowed into Yale or Harvard or
Princeton numerus clausus
I have heard of Yale by never heard of
George W Bush I've heard of Harvard but
I never heard of numerus clausus which
sounds to me like some kind of pig latin
i had heard of the pig boy i have never
heard of the beastie boys or the
scottsboro boys
how many people here have heard of the
scottsboro boys almost a third I'm just
a ham I had heard of the Beastie Boys or
the Scottsboro Boys I've never heard of
the Beastie Boys or the Scottsboro Boys
but I have heard singing boys what they
were called I forget I have never heard
America singing but I have heard of I
hear America singing I think it must
have been a book we had in school I
forget
I suppose it's a poem sponson poems a
person I'm school and the person who I'm
scolding but it's also the person of
myself there's a perverse Pinsky who
comes out in poems like this I think in
one of his poems he has one poem that
sort of is a disobedient adolescent it's
an angry adolescent calls itself I feel
like I basically remained an angry
adolescent which I certainly was and
it's amazing that some of it goes down
should I close with this yes maybe give
it back to explain where it comes in
there's a sequence of poems that are
it's called it was what the chat book
would be it will be that's come back
tonight it's called first thing to hand
first things to hand and the theory of
the is that the first thing I touch has
to be the occasion for a poem so it
would be my USAirways
prefer different wildcard and you would
talk about plastic and this one is
before they put the magnetic strip on it
it's delaminating and the layers of
what's happening to labor and health
plans form airlines that whoever was in
charge of laminating this the person who
invented it I hope they made money but
it's the clear plastic that makes it
glossy as delaminate blah blah blah and
the point is not ordinary life is so
interesting but that the occasion for a
poem is never really its subject Oh true
nightingale is not a better bird sailing
to Byzantium is not about Byzantium
they're about all the things Keats felt
about life that day all the things that
Yeats was feeling about life that day
and if each of us wrote a poem about the
little plastic card each poem would
express the personality and the
obsessions and the concerns of that
person if we even just wrote a paragraph
describing it we would be writing the
things that mattered to us
so there's a poem called book this one
called newspaper this one called jar of
pens there's one called other hand it's
the next thing you touch and what time
are we supposed to finish right now
when you finish this this is door door
the cat cries for me from the other side
it is beyond her to work this device
that I open and cross and close with
such ease when I mean to work it's four
panels form across the rude impaling
gatepost of redemption the rod a
dividing Pike or pal mounted and hinged
to swing between one place and another
meow
between the January vulva of birth at
the January of death store there are so
many to negotiate closed or flung open
or ajar valves of attention Oh kitty if
the doors of perception were cleansed
all things would appear as they are
infinite come in darling
growls comfortably near my feet I will
click the barrier closed again behind
you Oh sister will fellow mortal here we
are
[Applause]
you